who says this is a man's business
nothing on board would work without
stewardesses like Natasha Romanov
she helps ensure that everything in the
kitchen and dining room runs smoothly
I study cutter in control management and
I worked on totally in Poland very sweet
fresh
working straight through for four weeks
with no days off is a hard school but
everyone on board is in the same boat
there are no weekends or holidays on the
brave turn the 60 men are under time
pressure
the 80 windmills out in the North Sea
were supposed to be finished by now the
project is a 1.7 billion euro investment
wind and weather have frequently
interrupted work on the wind farm now
Lee callow has to make every hour count
the last windmill is his responsibility
but the last nacelle the machine house
is still on the ship's deck not on the
windmill Tower it's a bag falling in the
sail his bag full of water into the cell
12 leak hello is the lifting supervisor
on deck
if something happens here he's
responsible but he takes part in the
physical labor - just preparing lifts of
the cell now so we're we're hooking the
taglines onto the cranes of the crane
can control it during the lift
just write the times that we hook things
on and hook things off the hook just
keep a record from the FCM just for the
did their daily report one time we lift
someone off the deck what time we land
it after twelve exhausting hours on deck
he still has to do the paperwork in the
office his boss needs the report
immediately good people likely Kelo are
hard to find the company recruits from
many different professions electrician
good stuff and also if it's not
installation it could be commissioning
starting after turbine or the cable work
you'll be more flexible than but also we
have a lot of good blacksmiths steel
construction workers
pure pure kotovsky working out in the
exercise room the assembly fitters need
physical strength
Piatra an officer is here because he
likes it he's here every second day
you're feeling much better you feel fit
you feel much happy when you're sitting
in your cabin watching the movie every
day you are only getting much more fat
and you're not happy believe me on the
bridge stewardess Adriana's chess na is
cramming for a test to become a deckhand
she knows she's going to lose her job
like many crew members Fred Olsen
shipping is going to hire Filipinos at
lower wages but only the boss is
permitted to talk to us about this
in general everybody has a bottom line
for their operating costs it costs so
many thousand dollars a day to operate
this vessel and Fred Olson will always
be looking for the best deal in the
market to hide the vessel out for a
competitive day rate so they can compete
with the other companies installing
offshore windfarms costs are a big
pressure on the shipping company
Filipino seamen are well trained and
will also get responsible jobs on the
bridge
piotrek yaku Tomsky is lucky his
contract is not temporary he'll be
keeping his job
you are growing up with your experience
so you can join two other vessels from
the beginning to the end you are always
like in an adventure this is part of the
job to a trip home by helicopter after
many weeks at sea leave to go home but
what about the last windmill it's still
not finished